I said you have made this film almost
single-handedly it's there are many
others involved but I did do a lot of
things on it and and a terrific being so
well received so congratulations to you
and thank you for I know you're busy
right now but you you know we've known
each other while you flew out here I did
I hope that was an enjoyable experience
I flew well I I flew out I'm actually
doing kind of a whirlwind amount I last
week in New York City with our film open
I did 35 q and A's right and in the
weekend in three days right and and then
I'm doing six more here in Los Angeles
this weekend and I'm here on the show I
actually when I was flying here I got up
so early that I I just I was ravenous
when I got to the airport and I just
bought every piece of food they had like
I was just like apples in sandwiches I
don't know what's gonna happen up there
you know you don't know what they're
serving when they're serving it yeah and
so I got on the plane I was eating a
chicken salad sandwich and and the
flight attendant comes over and he goes
excuse me sir I'm aren't there nuts in
that sandwich and and I knew that there
were walnuts in the bread of the
sandwich and I knew that this was gonna
go badly so I just kept eating as I just
spawned it I was like no bread you know
and he goes because the woman two seats
down from you she has a nut allergy and
so she could go into shock because of
the nuts and I was like well I won't
feed them to her I will rub them on her
body you know
and he goes he goes no no it's it's a
serious allergy where she'll have a
reaction if there are nuts in the air
really yes I didn't know that I was like
if there are nuts in the air she should
not leave her house what's that is
insane she should learn how to drive a
car yeah so that way she can she can
keep the area uncontrolled and so I
looked over at the woman and I'm so
hungry and I'm halfway through the
sandwich and so I'm intent on finishing
the sandwich and I said um are you are
you serious I know are you you'll go
into reaction Birds nuts in the air I'm
still eating the same thank you it
switched for harmonica so chicken
sandwich salad sandwich Diddy that
Springsteen used to do quite a bit in
the early eighties the old I love that
tune and I go actually there's nuts in
the air and she goes yeah I'm you know
and and and I said to the guy go is
there anywhere where I can finish this
sandwich and I swear to God he goes you
can eat it in the bathroom really not
the airport bathroom the airplane
bathroom and I swear to God I said okay
I ate it in the bathroom I I didn't know
what else to do and not eat the sandwich
is what else you know it was like he was
throwing himself on a grenade for that
woman yeah he had to get rid of it
somehow yeah it was it was I I was
passed by point and so I'm eating the
sandwich in the airplane bathroom and
there's all kinds of chemical smells
coming at me and mayonnaise hey you know
yeah I had a revelation at that moment
that I I think I have a fecal airspace
no no really mysterious thing it's not
justify each species its my gosh did I
tell it's just the right time